DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Good
morning, afternoon,
or evening, wherever or
whenever you might be.
And welcome to Google
Next OnAir 2020.
We're honored and glad to have
you watching our Google Cloud
Cost Management session,
Mastering Your Billing Data
and Making it Useful.
Now, before we jump in,
I want to introduce you
to two handsome and
wise young gentlemen
who are excited to
bring you this content.
One, of course, yes, I'm biased,
is myself, Debo Aderibigbe,
and I'm a Google
Cloud Product Manager
who focuses on cloud
billing, specifically
in the areas of monetization
and GCP services alongside cost
management.
I'm also joined
by Dany, a partner
so amazing he doesn't
really need introduction,
but I'll have him do it anyways.
Danny?
DANY DAYA: Hey, everyone.
I'm Dany Daya.
I'm from Etsy.
I'm Program Manager at Etsy,
and I focus on cloud strategy
and operation.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Great.
So let's do a small
content check.
After all, though in some
cases you may have more time,
your internet time during
this COVID-19 period
is pretty valuable.
So if you care
about understanding
what is the use of
my resources in GCP,
and what are they
costing me, how
do I organize cost data so I can
do more useful things with it,
and how can I draw
insight with my cost data
that I can share with and
inform the right people,
then let's take this
journey together.
This is where you want to be.
Now, we're going to explore
the questions I just
raised in four ways.
First, an introduction,
or more specifically,
how a company like Etsy
arrives at managing cost
data in the cloud and
why it's necessary.
We'll then talk about some
simple and primary sources
of cost data and understand the
details of how it gets to you.
Then we'll dive
into a few use cases
and their corresponding
interfaces or visual output
to help jump-start you in how
you might analyze your cost
data and make it useful to you.
And then we'll finish
with a few tips
that you'll want to keep in mind
as you're managing your cost
data into the future.
So let's start at the beginning.
Many companies
have their reasons
for moving into
the cloud and then
unsurprisingly, alongside the
lack of equipment management
and heavy IT footprints,
cost savings is one of them.
Dany is going to
go ahead and talk
a little bit about the start
of Etsy's cloud journey.
Dany?
DANY DAYA: Thank
you very much, Debo.
Let me start by sharing
an overview about how Etsy
decided to move to the cloud.
For those who are not
familiar with Etsy,
Etsy is like global marketplace
for unique and creative good.
It's a home of a universe of
special extraordinary item
from unique, handcrafted
pieces to vintage items.
There are more than 2.8
million active sellers on Etsy,
and the number that I want
to draw your attention to
is that we have more than 66
million unique active listings
at Etsy.
This massive number
of active listings
require advanced
machine-learning capabilities
and search
capabilities to ensure
that buyers can find
easily what they are
looking for on our platform.
Such advanced capabilities
require more and more
infrastructure.
And maintaining such
infrastructure in data centers
would limit Etsy's goal
in continuous growth.
As a result of that, Etsy
started exploring cloud vendors
and moving to the cloud.
In 2017, Etsy made
that strategic decision
to move to the cloud.
We followed a very
complicated decision matrix
that contained more than
200 different factors
to evaluate different
cloud vendors.
As a result of that, we
decided to move with GCP.
If I want to summarize
all of those 800 factors
in kind of three main takeaways,
I would choose number one,
scalability.
Scalability is the ability
to scale on demand.
With data centers, you
have to plan ahead of time,
probably six to
nine months ahead
to do activities such as
provisioning, purchase
of hardware, installing
hardware, testing them,
and then running them.
On the cloud, things
are much, much faster.
You can do that in significantly
shorter time frame,
and guess what?
You can scale down after you
finish using your resources.
The second major thing
is sustainability.
Sustainability is one of
the major goals at Etsy.
We do track sustainability as
we track revenue and profit.
We find in Google a partner
that is aligned on this topic.
GCP commits to carbon neutrality
as well as energy efficiency.
Also, Google leverages
the latest technology
to achieve those goals.
This commitment made
us very comfortable
moving forward with Google.
This sort of thing is around
creativity and enablement.
We want to enable our
developers and engineers
to be able to use the latest
technologies out there
in the market in order
for them to continue
improving our platform and
serve our community of buyers
and sellers.
So the decision
was made in 2017.
In 2018, we started
the migration.
And earlier in 2020,
we successfully
completed this migration.
However, I would like
to share with you
and highlight some of the
non-engineering changes
that we went through.
The first thing is the change
in the type of the cloud cost
itself.
The cost on the
cloud is variable,
and it's very easy for
developers and engineers
to spend additional
resources, which
will lead to additional costs.
On the contrary, in
the data center world,
the costs were more
or less predictable
and managed by specific folks
in engineering and finance,
and at the end of the day, the
availability of the resources
were limited by the
capacity of the data center.
The second change is
associated with how
we purchase cloud resources.
If you want to think about
that in a cloud word,
every developer or
engineer has the ability
to spend additional resources.
In a way, we are having
a centralized procurement
of cloud resources, where
in the past everything
was centralized
between few folks
within engineering and finance.
The third change is kind of
a result of the prior two.
It's basically the
need of visibility.
With the increased number of
users and all of those users
have different use cases
and needs for visibility,
we found ourselves
that we have to provide
more visibility into
where the cost is
coming from on the cloud.
All of that required
us to follow
sort of a decentralized
cloud budget, governance,
and forecasting methods.
One of the way to
handle this challenges
is to adopt some of the cloud
cost governance or management
approaches.
And I'll hand over
back to Debo now
to walk you through some
of those approaches.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Thank you,
Dany, for that great lead-in.
It brings us back full
circle to the four
pillars that really define
Google Cloud Cost Management.
The first, of course,
is visibility.
That means that we provide you
a strong sense of transparency
through our interfaces,
documentation,
and APIs to help
you be able to find
and understand your
costs and your usage.
With accountability,
it means that we
enable you to
organize and allocate
your costs in ways that
align accountability
and budgets for the
appropriate business units
that you have in
your company or cost
centers or teams, whatever
makes the most sense.
Control, of course,
means that you
can make costs more
predictable with tools
that help you forecast, budget,
and essentially mitigate risk.
And finally, intelligence.
That means we give
you recommendations
and optimizations to help you,
at core, save money because who
doesn't want to do that?
And so now that we've
talked a little bit
about how Google Cloud
Cost Management works
and how Etsy has really
gotten to this point,
let's talk a little bit
more about data sources.
Hopefully you agree that
cost management in the cloud
is very important.
Let's take a look at where
that data comes from.
If we simplify, there are
three main simple methods
to take a look at your
costs and billing data.
In just a moment, we'll
dig deeper into each,
but we of course, have the
GCP invoice and statements,
we have the UI and the billing
console that contains reports,
tables, and views,
and then finally, we
have the GCP BigQuery billing
export, the most granular
and frequently updated source
of data in this group of three.
Accessible from the
Google Cloud console,
we have the GCP statements and
invoices on the documents page.
With few exceptions, if you
set up as an invoice account,
you'll see these once a
month on the fifth day
in the month following
the month that you
were using your GCP services.
Your invoice contains
information about you,
such as business
addresses, tax IDs,
as well as taxes or payments
for usage made within the month.
On it, the duration
of the invoice
month, you'll see
the highest level
of aggregation of
costs and products
and SKUs in terms of
your cost information.
If you're looking for
basic cost data that
can be handled and handed
over to finance, accounting,
and legal for simple bottom-line
numbers, this may be enough.
But as they say, if you
give a mouse a cookie,
they're probably going
to want a glass of milk.
So the billing console
in Cost Management
is where you're going to go.
The billing console has a
number of interface experiences
that help you to slice and
dice your data appropriately.
This includes interfaces
such as the cost overview
to see cost trends at a
glance, the cost table, which
serves as a more manipulable
form of your invoice,
and cost reports, which
allow you to filter,
aggregate, and zero in
on specific attributes
to do analysis.
The key insight I want
you to take away here
is that the things you are able
to do in the billing console
are the greatest
common denominator
amongst many types of customers
and companies that we serve.
We realize that one
size doesn't fit all,
and so we're working
constantly to make sure
that we improve our
views to make sure
that they fit most people.
Now, when you really
need to go custom
or you're missing a
particular view or insight
that you want to
take advantage of,
that's when you want to go to
the billing BigQuery export.
And hint, you're going to hear
me say this more than once,
you've got to turn it on.
It is an enabled feature.
So turn it on to make
sure that you have it.
You're going to thank me later.
The billing BigQuery
export enables
you to export detailed
Google Cloud billing
data, such as usage, pricing,
and cost estimate data
automatically through
the day to a BigQuery
data set that you specify.
You can then do all
kinds of things with it.
You can query it directly
for a specific insight,
or you could use additional
tools to build and visualize
data and look at dashboards.
You might also export
data to other formats
such as JSON or CSV to do other
programmatic manipulations.
Think of it as the
most customizable form
of your billing data.
Now, in the building and
monetization team at GCP,
we take the data in
and it flows like this.
We get usage at
different intervals,
depending on which
GCP service you're
talking about, such as GCS,
our storage service, Kubernetes
Engine, or Compute Engine,
and in a simplified sense,
we take that data in and
tally up the total usage we've
received and determine how
much it should cost based
on a number of factors,
such as price, discounting,
and other modifications.
That information then
takes multiple paths.
For one, we have a path to
payments to prepare invoices,
and then we also have two
paths to our reporting engine
for usage of the UI, and
then also the indexing engine
to make sure that we display
an export respectively.
Now, note that for what
matters to you, the export
updates more frequently.
Taking one more minute to
talk about that export,
one of its most special
powers is its flexibility.
Oh my, another hint?
Maybe you should turn it on.
Beyond the ability to write SQL
queries to integrate very, very
well with your other
visualization products,
you can use tools like Data
Studio or Looker or Tableau
to visualize this
data in a way that
makes it more effective to share
with others instead of having
them go directly into the
BigQuery tables and partitions
to understand the insights
that you'd like to share.
Now, it's also a source for
third-party integrators.
So if you're looking to use an
integrator like CloudHealth,
you might be able to
give them these insights
through your
BigQuery so they can
provide more multicloud
insights for you.
In the end, the BigQuery billing
export is very versatile.
So we've talked about
where your data comes from,
and I suppose it's time that we
think about crawling, walking,
and running with specific
use cases that more match up
to your everyday views of
how you deal with cost data.
How do we make sense
of all of this?
For a single use
case, let's go back
to one of the key questions
that we started with.
How can I organize my cost data
and make it easier to manage?
Well, to answer that question,
we got to start with a crawl.
And that crawl portion
of this use case
means understanding that
we like to call here
at Google Cloud the
flexible billing hierarchy.
The billing hierarchy
starts at the top
with the billing account.
It's one of your largest and
most important containers
for cost data.
We say that because it's the
level responsible for paying
for all of the resources
you use at GCP services.
So it's a fairly large
container that you
can use to assign to costs.
Underneath that
is a folder level.
It's commonly mapped to
larger business units and cost
centers, such as
DevOps or engineering.
And then you move on
to the project level.
This is the most common
container for resources
directly because
it's a good scoping
mechanism for individual teams
or for resources that you want
to keep together so you can do
other things like set access
policies or a label.
Below these are resources,
and examples of resources
include things like databases,
Kubernetes clusters,
and virtual machines.
Remember that a resource can
have one and only one project.
So if you want a way to identify
resources that span projects,
you want to make
effective use of labels.
Really, metadata that
you could use for,
among many other reasons,
costing your resources
and identifying them together.
Once you've understood all
this, you can start to walk.
All walking involves here is
diving into some of the billing
console changes that
you might find in terms
of attributes of your data.
And if you'd like to see it in a
specific way or to your liking,
you can use some of the filters
that appear in our interfaces
in Cost Management.
So whether it's something
like timing, usage or export
time, location, the region
your resources are running in
or other types of locations,
or container level, project
or folder, you can filter
to make the view exposing
information that you need.
And you can do quite the
same with the export,
except that it's a little
bit different of a format
and interface.
Here, if we take a brief look
at the BigQuery interface,
you can see that you
can write queries
to find very
specific information
that's custom to your needs.
And in the resulting data sets,
you can see all or just a few
of the attributes
in the table schema
that you want to see,
from the billing account
to usage to cost data,
right on down to labels.
But these are just
some of the basics.
Once you have all the
data, you can really run.
Let's switch over
to Dany so you can
get an idea of what advance
cost management looks like,
specifically for Etsy.
DANY DAYA: Thank
you very much, Debo.
Actually, before start running,
I want to highlight one thing.
The console Google make, of GCP
console that Debo mentioned,
is really powerful.
And I personally love
using it, especially when
it comes to forecasting
your future spend.
It has a lot of features
that I encourage all of you
to go try it.
However, at Etsy we have big
number of people using GCP,
and all of those people
are interested in knowing
their costs and
understanding it better.
To build such tools to enable
us to monitor at scale,
we had to rely on
two major inputs.
The first one, as you heard Debo
mentioning, the billing export,
which include a lot of the
data on the billing that's
happening on Google site.
So, as Debo mentioned,
please turn it on
if you plan on using
it in the future.
The second thing is
something we are calling it
as business inputs that
are specific to Etsy.
Think about stuff like a budget,
like a team, how are folders
and-- or sorry.
How GCP projects
are grouped together
under one team or cost center.
And I'll walk you through
an example of that in a bit.
We take those two inputs,
we merge them in BigQuery,
then we export the
output to Looker.
And Looker is a tool that
will enable us to slice
and dice the data as we like.
And I'm going to walk you
through those details in a bit.
So when I talk about
business inputs,
what am I talking about, really?
I'm sharing here with
you couple of example.
The first one is
mapping GCP projects
to business units or
teams or cost centers.
So what you're
seeing here is one,
we're representing all of
our-- or actually one column
representing all of
our GCP projects,
and the second column
is representing
all of the teams
or business units
that are running or owning
that specific GCP project.
Another example is
assigning a specific budget
for each business unit.
Again, we assign budgets
on monthly basis.
Your organization
might be doing it
on quarterly basis
or annual basis.
The goal here is
just to show you
how we can merge
all of this data
together with the billing data.
One thing that always
popped to my mind
is, what is the difference
between the labeling
and what Debo
presented and what we
are talking about here at Etsy?
In my opinion, those are
kind of the same thing.
It's just like at Etsy,
we decided to not burden
our engineers with the task
of maintaining and labeling
and continuing to label
resources as things change.
We decided to keep that
centralized under the program
management team.
What kind of output
we are looking
at when it comes to Looker?
The first thing is we
send automated emails
to the different stakeholders
who have interest in GCP costs.
Such emails notification could
include a variety of data.
What we are looking
here is a sample of one
of those graphs included
in the daily emails.
In fact, this graph, it
shows the account daily
spend broken down by GCP
service versus the budget.
So each column in this graph
represents the daily GCP spend.
Furthermore, we break each
daily spend by the GCP service.
And in this case, we are
looking at different colors.
Each color representing
a different GCP service.
The green is for Google Compute.
The orange is for cloud storage.
And if you can see, there is
light vertical black line.
This line represents
the daily budget.
Whenever a column
exceeds that line,
it means we have
a budget overrun.
Whenever the column is
below that budget line,
it means we have a budget
surplus on that specific date.
Now, this is another
interesting thing
I want to highlight to you.
Once you have all of
this data in Looker,
it becomes very easy
to visualize this data
in different ways.
And for a person
like me who is not
a big fan of
querying and coding,
Looker comes very, very
handy and useful to me.
With Looker, I can apply
specific filters and the change
specific selections
to transfer the graph
that we looked at earlier
into this graph, which
is the daily costs,
daily GCP costs.
Rather than looking at
the account program,
we are looking at the
specific business unit.
And rather than looking at
breakdown by GCP service,
we are looking at
breakdown by GCP project.
So an engineering manager
could look at this graph
and be able to track the
spend of every project
within his or her organization.
With that, I'm
going to hand back
to Debo to talk more about
some of the more advanced
Google monitoring tools.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Thanks, Dany.
Those graphs are pretty cool,
and they're informative.
So let's kind of stay
on the subject of budget
since you brought us there.
And you're probably asking
yourselves out there
in the audience,
is there anything
I can do in GCP to not just
budget but give insights
on how our budgets are
doing and performing
and inform the people who
need to know about them?
It's a great question, and
we do have a little bit
to help you here in GCP.
In fact, GCP Cost
Management gives you a place
to do it in a fundamental way.
You can set budgets through
the budgets interface
in the billing console,
and when you're
ready to walk with this
data, you can set things
like automated alerts.
You can set things like
cloud functions that
will manipulate your resources
when thresholds are reached,
and you can get and set
these budgets with APIs
and compare that
budget information
to what you have in
your usage and cost data
that you've gotten from your
billing BigQuery export.
But Dany and Etsy are once
again way ahead of the curve.
They've played with
these features,
and I think they love them.
Dany can confirm
that one for you.
But they've gone a
little bit further
to develop strategies that
work well for their business.
Dany, why don't you show
us what Etsy does when
you're running with that data?
DANY DAYA: Yep.
Let's do that.
So I'm going to walk you through
three different approaches
or three different
layers of tracking
the variation or the
trends in our GCP spend.
The first one, I look at
it as an account level.
So what you are looking
at here on this graph
is the daily, as well
as month-to-date,
variation from budget.
So if you look at
the orange bars, what
those orange bars are presents
is the daily variation
from budget.
If the bar is above zero, it
means we have a budget overrun.
And some of you
might be like, OK,
what does that even mean to me?
I'll try to explain it to you.
So if you look at
this graph, you
can see in the first
few days of the month,
we were having
positive orange bars.
However, at one point,
we realized at Etsy
that this is something
that's not a good trend.
And we don't want that.
So we went and investigated
what's the cause of that budget
overrun.
And we realized that
this is not the best
way of investing our money.
So we ended up killing some
of the workflows that are
causing this budget overrun.
And this is reflected in this
graph in kind of the middle
where you see that the
orange bars are now negative,
which means that
we have a budget
surplus on a daily level.
And also, it's represented
in the green line
that reflects the
monthly variation
as a percent from the budget.
It started high because we were
significantly above budget,
and it starts to go way
down towards the end
of the month, which is
what we intended on doing.
You can imagine that people
at finance and accounting
would appreciate
this kind of graph
because they love
tracking budgets.
But this graph might
not be super actionable
for engineering managers who are
interested more at the project
level.
So for this kind
of audience, I like
to introduce a
new dashboard that
shows that daily variation of
costs at the project level.
So if you look at
the upper graph here,
you are seeing all the project,
or actually, the top 15 or 10
projects that have the
biggest change day-to-day.
And the bars here present
whether the budget
or the cost of this
project increase day-to-day
or decrease.
This information can come very
useful for engineering managers
and guide them to the
point or the project that's
causing the budget variation.
They might not need to take
any corrective actions,
but the data is there for them.
The second graph,
and again, this
is one of the beautiful
features with Looker,
is giving similar
information here.
But rather than looking
at the project level,
we are looking at the
business unit level.
And rather than looking
at the daily change,
we are looking at
the monthly change.
So this graph provide
input for a director
to be able-- or
like a VP, probably,
to be able to understand which
business unit is changing
its spend months over months.
All of those gives us
an idea about finance
or like whole-level,
account-level, project-level,
but in reality, the
most important part
in this hierarchy
are the individuals,
the individuals who are
actually running the workflows.
And although the title
on the slide says run,
I need to tell you
that this is a sprint.
This is a lot of data
that we combine together.
The first two we talked about
earlier, the billing export
as well as the business
input from Etsy.
The third one that we introduced
here is resource labeling.
So why are we introducing
resource labeling?
The reason why we
introduce resource labeling
is that we have different
developers using the same GCP
project.
And within each project, each
developer or product initiative
is using specific resources.
So we need to associate
that specific resource
with the individual or the
product initiative that
is using it or
spending that resource.
And for that, we use a
specific automated tooling
to provide this labeling.
Once we have all of
this data, again,
we merge it together in Looker.
We are able to visualize
this heat map, which
shows the trailing five-day
cost for all of those workflows
that are either associated
with that individual
or with a specific
product initiative.
Also, we are using color-coding.
The color-coding makes
it much easier for people
to spot any changes
and anomalies.
In this case, if
for example, one row
that's representing
specific developer,
their color has
always been green.
If one day their
color is now red,
it means they are
spending more, and they
need to at least analyze
what's happening.
They might not need to
take any corrective actions
because some of that
spend is expected,
and we want it to happen.
So now that I gave you
an overview about how
we track and to trend the
budget variation at Etsy,
I want to be very
clear and realistic
in setting expectations.
It took us a long time to set
and put all of those monitoring
tools in place.
Understanding and mastering
the cloud in general, the cloud
billing, is not an easy task.
So it took us time,
and I would like
to share with you
some of the lessons
that Etsy learned
through this journey.
The first one is, try to focus
on one service at a time.
Depending on your account size
and your level of understanding
of cloud cost and
cloud management,
it might be really overwhelming
to try to understand everything
at the same time.
So my tip for you is strive to
focus on the main cost drivers
first.
And that could be either just be
service or a specific project.
Once you have a better
understanding of those,
try to scale them to
the tail of the spend.
The second thing that I
would encourage you to do
is test any monitoring or any
reporting with stakeholders.
At the end of the day, you might
have different stakeholders.
Each of them might want
different things to focus on.
So it's really important
to get those people aligned
and to hear their feedback when
you are doing your reporting
and monitoring.
At the end of the day, they are
the end-users of this product,
and you want to make sure that
they are on-board with it.
The third thing is
iterate and innovate.
Cloud cost management,
it's not a one-time action.
As long as you are
using the cloud,
you will have to revisit your
monitoring and reporting needs.
There might be a lot of reasons
why you might have to do that.
I'm just going to mention one
example, which happened lately
with us.
Google introduced a new product,
which is BigQuery Reservation.
And again, it's a product that
many users needs to use it.
And we realize that we
need to reflect with them,
and show the users how
much they are spending.
So we had to go
back to our worker
and try to slice and
dice this data again
to make it available for them.
With time, we realized we
become more familiar with it,
and you are very easily--
easier for you to
build those dashboard.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE:
Well, thanks, Dany,
for all the work
that you've done
in sharing what your
running style is with Etsy
and working with your cost data
to make it especially useful
for you.
I have a little bit
of parting advice
to supplement that
information that Dany
has given you to make
sure that you get the most
out of your cost
data as you continue
on that lifelong journey.
Or maybe not lifelong,
but at least as long
as you're working
with that business
to make sure that
you get the cost
data to be correct and
accurate and useful.
So the first, again,
I promised you
I was going to say it
several times, turn
billing BigQuery export on.
It's an extremely
useful data set,
and in terms of making sure that
you have it available for you
from the beginning of your cloud
journey to wherever you may be
now in the present
and into the future,
it has to be enabled so that
you can generate the data set
and have it appear
where you need it to be.
Secondly, you should analyze
your cost detail and reports
instead of using the
invoice for analysis.
I've heard it commonly
amongst many customers
that they looked at the invoice
to try to get a better sense of
whether or not their
costs were accurate,
but really, we even got a cost
detail table that actually
mimics very closely the
amount of information that's
in the invoice and then allows
you to selectively filter
and look at more granular
versions of that data
to the point where it's
going to help you and be
more accurate and active
at the moment in given time
that you're looking at it.
Then, of course,
want to make sure you
have a labeling strategy.
You'll really thank
me for this one later.
Labeling allows you to cross-cut
and deliver certain attributes
upon which we'd
like to make sure
that there's accountability and
cost data specifically tagged
to.
So make sure that
your labeling strategy
has a little bit
of flexibility so
that if your business
changed, let's say
you go through a
reorg or you need
to do something new in
terms of the applications
you develop, that you're
labeling strategy is not
so pigeonholing that you
can't change it and still
have it tell you the type
of cost data that you need.
Then, watch out for
querying gotchas.
I hear often from
customers that they
looked at usage time instead
of the time of export,
which is almost a slice of
time where you're querying
to see when the data
was exported as opposed
to what was driving its costs
at the time that it was used.
So make sure you use the
right one when you're actually
writing your query.
So look closely.
Then finally, create
a query library.
You'll find that sometimes,
when you're using tools
like Looker or Tableau,
that a query is
the basis of a window
into the information
or view that you want to
create that will eventually
become a dashboard as
that information matures.
So if you can keep a
collection of those things,
they'll always
remain useful for you
in terms of making
decisions later
about what you'd like
to do and who you'd
like to share that data with.
So with that, we
come to our close.
There's plenty you can
learn about Cost Management,
and we hoped that you learned a
lot from hearing from us today,
but just in case you
couldn't get enough,
we do have another
session about what's
new in Cost Management
and the cloud, CST 101,
that I hope you take a look at.
And below on the
slide, I've given you
several resources
that might help
you more familiarize
with cost management
in general and Looker
and other tools
that might be useful for you in
your cost management journey.
But in the meantime, I want
to make sure that I thank you,
the audience, for
giving us your eyeballs
and your ears and your time, and
say, this is Debo signing off.
And Dany, hope you get
to say goodbye too.
DANY DAYA: Thank you very
much, everyone, for being here.
Thank you very much,
Debo, and please be safe.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Yep.
Thank you very much,
and thanks once
again for joining us and
Google Next OnAir 2020.
Goodbye, everyone.